[موسيقى]
تتجه انظار المهتمين بالفن الاسلامي الى
مدينه جده بعد انطلاق بناء الفنون
الاسلاميه الحدث الاول من نوعه في العالم
الذي يحتفل التاريخي الاسلامي ويضم بين
جناباته نوادر المقتنيات والمخطوطات
والقطاع الفريده
[موسيقى]
صمم ما معرض بناني على مساحه
288,000 متر مربع يضم 5 صالات ضخمه
وبمشاركه 40 فنان سعوديا وعالميا قديم من
24 دوله يعرضون اعمالهم الفنيه التي تحكي
تاريخها وارث العالم الاسلامي بطرق معاصره
تحاكي الماضيه والحاضر
الفنانين والمصممين والحرفيين ان هم
يتقربوا من موضوع ويحاولوا ان هم ينتجوا
في حاجه مختلفه وفكره اول نسخه لبناء ل
فنون اسلاميه هي اول البيت هو مكه المكرمه
والمدينه المنوره وازاي مكانتهم مهمه جدا
بالنسبه لنا كمسلمين
[موسيقى]
العمل هو سلسله المعرفه فكره باختصار بوثق
سند الخط العربي في مكه المكرمه يعني الى
كتمت الوحيد طبعا خلال 1400 عام بيذكر
اسماء الاشخاص اللي ساهموا في نقل هذه
المعرفه حتى وصلت لنا اليوم الحاضر
الاعمال
عجبني انه اول شايف الدخله اللي هي القبله
يعني لها معنى قوي لاحد ما يعرف عن ديننا
او ما يعرف عننا عن حضارتنا
[موسيقى]
بناني للفنون الاسلاميه قدمه في نسخته
الاولى في جده ما يقارب 280 قطعه اثريه
معارتا من مؤسسات المحليه والدوليه
بالاضافه الى الحوارات الفنيه القيمه التي
يستضيفها المعرض طوال 3 اشهر
لصباح العربيه سلطان السلامي جده